say my name
Eisenberg
God damn right
people have often asked could someone
really become a Walter White could they
start murdering people could they start
cooking math yes it's possible you need
to have certain things aligned hey GQ
I'm Dr Eric bender and I'm back this
time to talk about anti-heroes TV shows
used to be much more clear-cut who are
the heroes and who were the villains now
it's a big mashup let's take a look at
shows including Mad Men Breaking Bad and
The Sopranos
an anti-hero is someone that doesn't
have the traditional moralistic sense or
characteristics that we see in a hero
but there are certain aspects of them
that we do root for the three qualities
that most anti-heroes display are
narcissism psychopathy and
machiavellianism together we call this
collection the dark Triad let's look at
each of those narcissism is the idea
that you are super special and there's
this pursuit of unlimited wealth or
power you think you deserve extra
admiration psychopathy is a personality
construct meaning that it's a collection
of different characteristics that
includes being callous being uncaring
lying repeatedly but the one that is
most influenced by the environment is
the machiavellianism it's the actual
learning to manipulate other people and
that can occur because of the
environment you grow up in there's an
idea that an environment might actually
make someone have to learn how to
survive and maybe they survive by
whatever means necessary Walter White
I was there
and I watched her die
I watched her overdose and choked to
death
Walt becomes an anti-hero very early on
maybe even the first episode because
here's this guy that we can identify
with feeling badly for him and he
decides to cook meth so there's the
oppositional Force to being a hero is
that this guy is going to start doing
something highly illegal some studies on
mess suggest that if you start using it
and you use it continually you've
shortened your life by about 15 years
after the first couple times so he's
doing something that really clearly is
detrimental to humanity
[Music]
[Applause]
this tire shine huh oh my God
when we first meet Walter he is almost a
pitiful character but as he starts to
try to change his life he does more and
more amoral things murder becomes second
nature lying becomes second nature this
guy becomes what some might call a
sociopath which means that Society has
impacted him enough for him to really
develop these Psychopathic traits I
think that's a bit too simple to say
that I think he had these things in him
from the beginning he had this idea that
he was owed something that he was taken
advantage of he starts to blame other
people and that's something narcissists
do often then it's everybody else's
fault it's not theirs even though he's
not Heisenberg yet he's on his way Vince
Gilligan creator of the series talked
about the moment when he really thought
that Walt became Heisenberg and and
cemented this criminal life was when he
took the fulminating Mercury and blew up
tuko's building
this
is not meth
at that point Walt does get some power
he even introduces himself as Heisenberg
so he's now this full-blown
narcissist slash anti-social person it's
also interesting that he chose
Heisenberg as his moniker Heisenberg was
a physicist who also was successful with
chemistry and had lung cancer so while
equating himself with his Nobel
prize-winning person and seeing himself
in this new light we also see Walt's
appearance change over time at first the
hair falls out so he shaves his head
which is very common for people who are
going to have chemotherapy and know that
they're going to have treatment that's
going to cause their hair to fall out
but he soon embodies it and he's got
this new way to dress and a pork pie hat
and he is Heisenberg Walt and Jesse's
relationship was very interesting Walt
has manipulated Jesse in many situations
I think that Walt has appreciated Jesse
because he couldn't be Heisenberg
without him at the end there's that
moment when he saves Jesse and that's
Heisenberg digging in and having brought
out that Walt part of him again the part
that could care about him as a person
there's a term in Greek called hamartia
which means the Fatal flaw of a
character that brings them down Walt's
narcissistic ego and the bruising of it
is what his homartia is he opens up the
case again with Hank Hank goes chasing
after him because he says oh you know
Gus Gus was copying someone he clearly
wasn't the genius Waltz hurt that people
would think of Gus as a genius and not
know it was really him part of being a
malignant narcissist is to hurt other
people
we have plenty of examples of Walt doing
that purposefully he tells Jesse I
watched Jane die same thing with
stealing Holly
I think in part that was because he
wants his daughter but he's also really
out to make his wife upset
now
one of the interesting things about
having Psychopathic traits or even being
a psychopath is that you can still love
your children you can still have moments
there is an interesting article called
The Hidden suffering of the psychopath
that talks about Psychopaths really not
knowing how to connect with other people
they're so good at tricking other people
because they can see how you're supposed
to interact with others but they don't
know how to do that
Walt has these Psychopathic traits but
he does have moments of being able to
connect and he leaves Holly in the fire
engine to be found we can look at an
experiment that actually might show us
that this is possible the zimbardo
prison experiment was an experiment run
out of stand for decades ago in that
experiment students were assigned to
roles of either prisoners or prison
guards and things had to be ended early
because people ended up taking their
roles so seriously and actually becoming
those individuals they became prisoners
they became prison guards there was
abuse of the prisoners there were all
kinds of character traits that came out
in people that were awful
Tony Soprano
how about the fact that I hate my son
like come on me sitting on the computer
in his underwear
wasted his time in some chit chat room
going back and forth with some other
jerk off giggling like a little
school girl it was one of the first
times we see a someone realistic
depiction of therapy on television and
we see how people get frustrated with it
at one point he says therapy is a jerk
off you know it I know it his therapist
like I actually don't know it and that's
some version of something I hear from
patients all the time they don't usually
use those vocabulary words but they will
tell me they get frustrated when is this
going to end what is the point of all
this what am I supposed to do with all
these feelings when we look at
personality disorders
we consider is someone's interaction
with the world around them vastly
different from the cultural norm he's
ensconced in the culture of the mafia
where we expect people to be violent to
do the things they need to do in order
to get what they want so in some ways
he's functioning quite well in that
culture
but take him out of that and put him
into the culture at large his family
culture he is not able to do it he
doesn't know how to do it and that can
be for a number of reasons he grew up in
a family that was a Mafia Family he saw
his father take someone's finger off for
not paying them he witnessed a lot of
violence clearly his mother was very
argumentative likely had traits of
narcissistic personality disorder as
well as some other personality disorder
traits
you disobeyed your old man in order to
give it a belt
[Music]
but I gotta say
a lot of boys your age would have run
like a little girl
there's a term called adverse childhood
experience or Aces those are events that
happen in a child's life traumatic
events often Tony has a number of Aces
if you go down the list and take an ace
inventory very interesting to see where
he lands he's an anti-hero because he is
someone who just like us is trying to
have a family get through the day-to-day
life trying to deal with things that are
out of his control such as his son's
depression
he's really trying to do his best we
empathize with that we can root for that
Tony really spills his guts in his own
Tony way saying he's got the world by
the balls but he keeps feeling like a
loser he feels like a loser because he
does not know how to connect to people
he doesn't know how to go about saying
to his daughter let me be curious about
you let me make space for you he doesn't
know how to tell his son this is awful
instead he says snap out of it or you
got to stop doing this you gotta do this
he doesn't know how to Father his kids
and kids don't come with an instruction
manual in his case the idea of getting
help means he's not doing something
right he is not good and he can't stand
that feeling
Don Draper Donna's a great line where he
says people tell you who they are but we
ignore it
cause we want them to be who we want
them to be
so everybody sees down as this
charismatic
really handsome guy seems to be in
control of a room can command an
audience but he is showing us who he is
he is hypocritical he's having Affairs
he is somebody who doesn't treat people
well we don't want to see that we see
this facade of his and that's often true
with someone who can be narcissistic you
get an image of them that they've
presented but underneath is a real
fragility and that's what we see and
done is this fragile nature of wow you
really suffered a lot it would be
impossible to look at Don Draper without
looking at his history when he was a
child he was born to a mother who died
in childbirth he watched his father die
at age 10 when his father was kicked by
a horse later he ends up being raised in
a whorehouse in Pennsylvania the closest
that he got to feeling nurtured was when
a prostitute used to give him Hershey
bars if he would pickpocket the Johns
and give her the money yet we can't just
keep that in mind and feel sorry for him
but because he does these things that
are not really moral that really are
upsetting to those around him that
destroy the fabric of his family with
his daughter he does stand up for her he
stands up for Sally when the mother's
mistreating her but at the same time
Sally has that classic line when she's
in the car with her mother who just
offers her a cigarette I'd rather have
you do it in front of me than behind my
back
foreign
my father's never given me anything
so there is something broken in this
relationship as well Donna touch a
terrible upbringing that when he was
fighting in the Korean War and his
Superior died he switched the dog tags
with that person and assumed a whole new
identity so dick Whitman was no more on
record and Don Draper
lived on Don is driven to never
feel what he felt as he was a young
person and he starts to pitch the
carousel to Kodak and he brings up the
idea of nostalgia and with it he says
there's that painful place there's
there's pain there's pain for him to
think back
Teddy told me that in Greek
Nostalgia literally means
the pain from an old wound
it's a twinge
in your heart
far more powerful than memory alone
foreign
[Music]
at this point he's already a philanderer
his marriage is not great his
relationship with his kids is starting
to fracture he looks at these scenes
where he was important he was someone he
was a father he was a loving husband he
seems to offer some empathy to some
people but it's interesting he can't do
that with his own children in some way
he can't be there with his wife
he's afraid of this emotion that's often
when I see people come to me in therapy
is when they've realized that their
coping mechanisms are not helping them
avoid what they've been feeling during
covet in particular a lot of people came
in because they couldn't go to work
anymore where they poured their efforts
and that allowed them to turn away from
things that are really hard to deal with
[Music]